just before you roll off I want you to
go back to we've written these questions
and I actually want you to highlight
something for me
question two right see all these guys
down here the thing that they share in
common these are these things in the
brackets okay these guys here right now
we call these things all do the same
name because they're all inside the
brackets a pair of terms right you know
when you've got a arm a vehicle which
has two wheels what do you call that you
call it ah you call it a bicycle right
if it's got a motor running then you
call it movement now this has to not
wheels but to terms so we call these
things this thing this thing and this
thing
okay they're not bicycles they're
binomials okay
all that means is this sound this term
along began to you this work suffix
Gnomeo ah it comes from the word that
just means so you know these are
algebraic terms binomial just means
you've got two of them and if you had
more you call it a polynomial because
poly means many right lots and lots and
lots and I'm a mother okay now these
binomials are what we're going to focus
on in this lesson which is why stuck
these into the review questions so there
hey I'd like you to make underneath all
of your review questions is so this is
can you see the binomial part of this
question right the binary part is the
bit with two terms in it which is here
that's a binomial and we're about to
expand it so it's a binomial expansion
just like before like with these
questions over here the brackets just
mean okay whatever you've got a key on
which is actually multiplication right
just do it to everything inside do to
everything so root three times five how
would you bite that 5 root 3 so far so
good
what about these you know some surd
boars now how to deal with these right
rather than two I can combine them into
one third which is it that's it that was
not complicated that's it
yeah okay but it starts to get tricky up
pretty quickly so you
okay so I haven't made it a lot more
complicated but just enough but maybe
you're looking at that and you're
wincing a little bit okay that's alright
take your time
I can deal with this just the same way I
did before maybe you will find it
helpful like I often do to mentally
remind myself that this guy gets
multiplied by everything inside so I do
it like this there's the first
multiplication and then here is the
second modification I actually draw
those in so I know what I'm doing
so let's just deal with the first one
for it seven times five for you to
probably the easiest way is deal with
these guys first the whole numbers and
then deal with the sense okay so four by
five 2013 7 times 3 to 14 since the
first part and then we're on to the
second pairing for root 7 times minus
3/7 watch after that sorry
so what am I going to get so the first
thing is definitely - right the root 7
times root 7 will become just 7 so 4
times 7 will be 28 okay with that
think about it let me pull this out
separately in case your bit confused
Frankie
he uh he and he um if all like AP was a
question was this let's make it positive
for now okay again just like I did with
this guy like you guys were okay with
2014 right okay with that route 7 is
kind of if you could write it as one
route 7 I mean it's a bit redundant you
don't have to but it's true isn't it
it's seven is one route 7 well I'm going
to do it just like I did before I'll do
my whole numbers first 4 times 1 and
then I'll do my search next what route 7
like what it is is the number that you
multiply by itself to give you 7 so that
part just becomes 7 so a we add but
remember you can combine answers
together and what you get might not end
up being a certain that's its way yeah
okay
do I have it mix it so far so good
okay let me give you a harder one is
something the last one I do right now
maybe we'll see how we go
okay so we're ramping it up a little bit
now remember I showed you before these
errors you might like to find them
useful just so you make sure you don't
forget any terms well as your questions
become more difficult those errors
become all the more useful so let me
make there's something over to space
don't quite need this anymore however
look at this this question as messy as
it looks is directly parallel to this
question see that watch I'll show you
how they the same C squared plus 7c it
came from here
first pair second pair do you see C
squared + 7 C what about these guys when
they come from 7c and seven sevens
do you agree now exactly the same thing
is happening here it's just you've got
Sun that's all so I'm going to throw my
errors so I can see what I'm doing for
is going to get multiplied here and here
and then minus root three is going to
get multiplied here in here okay so
watch let's do this one step at a time
in fact just to make it even more
obvious I'll use these colors so you can
see which is a which 4 times 2 root 3
deal with the whole longest first 4 by 2
is 8
are there any other square roots flowing
out look there so it's just a preacher
okay that's the first one 4 times 1
nice okay
that was what's a hug I've dealt with my
red pants you see that now I'm able to
wear any ones down here okay this one's
been tricky up minus root 3 times 2 root
3 do be a whole numbers what do you hold
on is you've got a minus 1 and 2 do you
agree today probably minus 2 then you
deal with your sons root 3 x 3 3 root 3
Times root 3 is just 3 it's just so I've
got minus 2 and I've got 3 that's - ok
it is my 6 once you put on the gun blast
it - 3 3 times 1 okay well done so now
I've done the expansion but I should tie
this up I should I can write this a lot
better have a look which other like
terms
a root 3 and minus root 3 so how do you
read threes by the end excellent
then you do your whole numbers plus 4
minus 6 minus 2 and Johanna okay so
there's a bit of mental effort involved
to unpack what's happening - yeah but
you guys can manage it